Welcome back everyone it's Charlie a
first look at the new Marvel Kraven the hunter
movie was released so we'll break it all down
they're also about to release a longer version
of the trailer they released at cinemacon
earlier this year including both red band
and PG-13 versions of the trailer the reason
they have to do that is because the movie is
going to be one of the first rated R movies that
Marvel and Sony have done together as part of this
Spider-Man characters like the larger Spider-Man
universe so if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos if you
didn't see it in your feeds the last couple of
days they released another preview of Aaron
Taylor-Johnson from the trailers as Kraven
inside the Venom Spider-Man connected Universe of
Marvel movies this is from earlier in the movie
when he's getting ready to kill a bunch of thugs
that have come for him it's meant to show some of
his abilities how easy it is for him to take down
really hardcore thugs like he doesn't need a whole
lot of Technology he goes very low-fi that's
why he's just wearing the jacket he's supposed
to be very old school during the movie like you
see him take down big game across the country
in the comics funny coincidence this is a giant
Spider-Man game coming out later this year about
the same time that this movie is coming out I've
already done a trailer video for that Spider-Man 2
so I'll link it below in the comments that's what
we call Synergy but the trailer they released at
cinemacon also explains how Kraven connects with a
larger Spider-Man movies just in general and even
though they didn't allow the cinemacon trailer
footage online everybody was going crazy about
how good it looked so the odds are that this will
not be morbin time again thankfully it seems like
this movie is actually going to be pretty decent
it'll be Marvel's first hardcore rated R movie
they've done since the Deadpool movies Deadpool 3
will be like the next big one they actually just
shuffled the dates on all that stuff so we'll
get to watch Deadpool 3 a little bit sooner
too if you forgot there is a Crave in the hunter
movie being released later this year it's part
of this Sinister Six crossover story that Sony
and Marvel have going on in the background with
the Venom movies a bunch of the other live-action
Spider-Man spin-offs we make all the morbius it's
morbin time jokes but like they set up Sinister
Six in that post-credit scene with the version of
the vulture from the MCU so we know that they're
gonna do a Sinister Six movie I've already done
a bunch of videos about that and even though we
make all the morbin time morbius jokes there were
some deleted scenes from that movie featuring
Kraven Easter eggs setting up this version of
Kraven I think the idea is they wanted to fold
him into the universe through the morbius movie
but they had all those Spider-Man easter eggs
they wound up taking out like a bunch of deleted
scenes featuring different versions of Spider-Man
like Tobey Maguire Andrew Garfield Tom Holland's
version of Spider-Man all kind of mixed together
a lot of the Multiverse stuff that's going on
in those movies right now too is tied to what's
happening with them building up to Avengers 5 King
Dynasty and Avengers 6 Secret Wars because for
instance Spider-Man across the spider-verse big
Multiverse movie spider-verse movie with a bunch
of different characters from different universes
that movie is also building up to Avengers
Secret Wars we're gonna see the spider-verse
characters in live-action versions of themselves
during Secret Wars so all the Multiverse stuff is
finally starting to make sense Kraven is supposed
to be part of that but this first Kraven movie
is still meant to be relatively earth-based
within the Venom Universe it takes place in
Venom's Universe Aaron Taylor John content is
playing Kraven bet you didn't see that coming
that's right we have another character from
the Multiverse playing different characters in
different Marvel movies that's starting to happen
more and more like there's just so many Marvel
movies coming from Sony from Marvel in the MCU all
the different places eventually you're going to
start to see some characters playing completely
different characters in some Legacy characters
like Andrew Garfield Spider-Man Toby Maguire
Spider-Man coming back Hugh Jackman Wolverine
also a good example of that the Kraven the hunter
teaser trailer began with a couple short scenes of
vtaking out this military Convoy of villains in a
very bloody fashion remember the movie's supposed
to be r so it's supposed to be pretty bloody he
bites one dude's nose off he kills another with a
large hunting Spirit like Kraven's trademark spear
from the comics another one gets his face caught
in one of Kraven's very medieval looking hunting
trap devices mangling him super bad then they
started to tie things to the larger Spider-Man
spider verse there was a scene of Kraven versus
the Rhino so the Rhino is meant to be one of the
major Spider-Man villains like one of the core
original Spider-Man villains in the movie all
Alessandro navola is playing the character and
because the movie is R it'll be a much darker
hardcore version of the character most people
when they think of the Rhino they think Apollo
giamatti's more comedic version of the Rhino the
Kraven teaser trailer footage also made it clear
that this version of the Rhino won't be like Paula
giamatti's Rhino he won't wear an actual suit like
it won't be a mechanical version of the character
it'll actually be a biological version a little
bit more comic book accurate the way the actor
talked about his character he said that he'll
start out as a normal human and take a serum
that will transform his body so something similar
to what you saw in The Incredible Hulk movie with
the Abominations transformation in that movie
he'd been given the super soldier serum which
had already given him a certain level of powers
like Captain America level Powers then the leader
recreated the accident that gave the hook his
gamma powers and some of the Hulk's blood which
is why he turned into that monstrosity looking
version otherwise he would have looked a little
bit more like the Hulk he'll become way bigger
like you would expect the Rhino to be from the
comics the full tagline for the movie that was in
the trailer read no one survives the hunt Russell
Crowe is playing Kraven's father from the comics
the previous Kraven the hunter who passes the
mantle down to his son he also had a pretty crazy
relationship with his father too like it was not
a buddy buddy relationship I believe we're also
supposed to see a version of the chameleon in the
movie because he's also Kraven's illegitimate
brother the full official trailer will release
online around Spider-Man across the spider-verse
when that comes in June big reminder that the
movie is also coming out later this year too
they've been pretty quiet about it lately but
based on all the cinemacon footage in the trailer
it sounds like it's actually going to be pretty
decent after the morbius movie bet you did not see
that coming there have been a bunch of versions
of Kraven's origin story most people remember
him from Spider-Man the Animated Series in the
90s they did kind of a speed run version of his
origin during that that's a little bit different
from the comics originally in the comics he was
born to Russian aristocrats the Kravenoff family
his father was abusive and it was forced to flee
Russia after the Bolshevik Revolution to the UK
later to the United States eventually his father
dies his mother goes insane is committed to an
asylum which which is Infested by spiders and it
haunts Kraven's memory for the rest of his life so
it kind of informs his hatred of Spider-Man
although technically that isn't the reason
why he wants to kill Spider-Man Kraven becomes a
champion Hunter by adulthood and spends a lot of
time hunting big game in Africa he gains his extra
powers like he actually does have some biological
powers from a special potion that he steals from
a witch doctor the level of powers that they give
him are kind of like super soldier like abilities
he has enhanced strength speed senses decelerated
aging all the things that you would want to
have as a hunter eventually Kraven learns about
Spider-Man's existence and senses that he will be
his greatest Challenge and he just tries to catch
Spider-Man and kill him for the challenge of it
so it's not like Spider-Man accidentally killed
his parents or anything like that or did anything
terrible to him it's just that he's constantly
seeking out greater challenges to prove himself
the greatest hunter in existence he eventually
does wind up pulling that off during Kraven's
Last Hunt storyline probably one of Kraven;s best
stories of all time I don't think they're going
straight to that story in the first Kraven movie
but I think they'll try to work up to that if they
do Kraven sequels there might be some Easter eggs
for that in the first Kraven movie they've been
kind of cagey about which version of Spider-Man
exists in Venom's Earth because vulture mentioned
him in the morbius movie and morbius takes place
on Venom's Earth I know there's tons of questions
about the designation of all the different Earths
because in the Spider-Man across the spider-verse
trailer Miguel O'Hara specifically mentions mcu's
Spider-Man and Doctor Strange during the
events of Spider-Man no way home messing
up the Multiverse but get me started on Doctor
Strange and a little nerd back on Earth 199999
all right what just happened you also might
remember that they featured a comic book
accurate Rhino during Spider-Man no way home
it's meant to be the Rhino from this movie
when the Multiverse starts to tear open more
and more of the Spider-Man villains from the
Multiverse start to come through the Rhino
was featured here comic book accurate Rhino
now it's meant to be the Rhino from The Kraven
movie they had a ton of comic accurate versions
of other Spider-Man characters and villains
in this scene so Kraven the hunter was also
one of them with his spear now it's meant to be
the Aaron Taylor Johnson version in this movie
so it's kind of like they were teasing all these
upcoming movies with these villains that showed
up which I think a lot of us assumed at the time
like are they teasing that these characters are
going to start showing up eventually there's
a version of doppelganger who's the six-arm
evil Spider-Man a lot of people thought that that
could be superior Spider-Man 2 so you could pick
either one superior Spider-Man or doppelganger
just one of the six armed versions of Spider-Man
there was a comic accurate scorpion not the MCU
version who was more of a mechanical scorpion I
think this was supposed to be black cat who was
also supposed to appear in another live-action
spin-off movie at at some point this is another
version of Mysterio from a different Universe not
the MCU version and I think this is meant to be a
comic accurate version of Madame Webb setting up
the Madame Web movie with Dakota Johnson that
they just finished filming a while ago it is
supposed to be kind of like Terminator in the
Spider-Man universe with Spider-Man characters
like a character comes from the future to try
and erase Spider-Man from the past I don't know
if this is meant to be a completely new version
of Spider-Man somewhere from Another Universe or
Andrew Garfield's Spider-Man from his timeline
or Toby Maguire's Spider-Man from his timeline
and they didn't say much about Spider-Man 4 but
they did confirm that Kevin feige in the Marvel
people are actually working on it right now they
know what the story is going to be the planned
release date right now is summer 2025 so they
won't start filming for a little while but they
did confirm that Daredevil and Kingpin will be big
parts of the movie the Marvel people said what's
happening during Daredevil born again will heavily
influence the plot of Spider-Man 4 what happened
with Kingpin becoming mayor of New York City so
we might actually get Spider-Man and Daredevil
teaming up against Kingpin during Spider-Man 4
but there will be other plot happening during
the movie like it isn't just about what's
happening with Kingpin and Daredevil like
there'll be other Spider-Man villains in the
movie but generally it'll be more of a classic
Spider-Man type of story like he's got a classic
version of the suit now it's much more Lo-Fi way
more friendly neighborhood Spider-Man than say
like the Iron Man Stark Tech version of Spider-Man
I'll do more Spider-Man 4 videos when we get
more details about the movie and more Kraven
trailer videos when they start releasing more
footage but if you have any questions about
what's happening with all the movies just write
them Below in the comments everyone click here
for that brand new Flash trailer video with a
whole bunch more Batman and click here for my
Spider-Man beyond the spider-verse teaser
trailer video for that next spider-verse
movie thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!